All right.
We are first going to start
talking about bond strengths.
You know that we have been
drawing these energy interaction
curves as a function of r.
And we have defined,
here, a bond association energy
E sub d as that energy
difference from the bottom of
this well to the separated atom
limit.
And let me consider the
separated atom limit,
now, to be a separated methyl
group and a hydrogen atom,
because I want to talk about
the CH bond.
This is the bond association
energy for CH in methane.
But now, what we are going to
do is change our definition a
little bit.
Instead of talking about a
dissociated energy,
a bond energy,
we are going to talk about a
bond enthalpy.
And I am going to represent the
bond enthalpy by delta H.
It turns out that in the
laboratory we can more easily
measure a delta H,
a bond enthalpy,
rather than a bond energy.
We can do so because most of
the experiments we do are at
constant pressure.
When we do an experiment in the
lab that is at constant
pressure.
And the relationship between
delta H and delta E is the
following.
Delta H is equal to delta E
plus delta PV.
Now, where this relationship
comes from is a subject of a
great discussion in 5.60,
in Chemical Thermodynamics.
You will see that if you take
5.60.
At the moment,
we are just going to take this
as a given.
But I will tell you that,
although delta H and delta E
differ for gases,
the difference is on the order
of 1% to 2% for gases between
delta H and delta E.
They are both an energy,
but we are going to call it an
enthalpy.
That is actually what we
measure, typically,
in the laboratory.
For solids and for liquids the
numbers are essentially the
same, but for gases there is a
1% to 2% difference.
So if you are doing an exact
calculation, you really do need
to know that number exactly,
you need to get the bond
enthalpy.
And, in fact,
if you go and you look up bond
strengths they will,
for the most part,
all be bond enthalpies and not
bond energies.
There is a more extensive table
of bond enthalpies than there is
for bond energies.
So we are going to talking
about delta H for a bond now.
And in thermodynamics,
as again you will see in more
detail in 5.60,
we always need a standard
state.
We are always going to be,
for the most part,
measuring things relative to
one another.
And so we need a common ground,
we need a standard state.
And what your book uses,
and what most people now use
for a standard state,
is the pressure one bar.
The standard state really
refers to the pressure and
actually not the temperature.
One bar is equal to 10^5
Pascals.
And a Pascal is a kilogram
meter per second squared.
10^5 kilogram per meter second
squared.
And the relationship between
bar and atmosphere is one
atmosphere, 1.01325 bar.
An atmosphere is 1.01325 bar.
I am sorry?
Okay.
And so to represent this
standard state here,
we are going to put a nought
up here.
We are going to put a
superscript up here.
This is going to be delta H
nought.
That is going to represent our
standard state.
This slide is what we will do
now.
On the first slide here,
what I have is bunch of bond
enthalpies.
And these are bond enthalpies
where all of them are for CH
bonds.
The first one is for the CH
bond in methane.
The second one for the CH bond
in ethane.
The third for the CH bond in
CHF three.
And what you can see is that
they are all about 400
kilojoules per mole.
They are not all exactly the
same, and they shouldn't be.
They are different molecules.
The bond strength really does
depend on the individual
molecule.
But they are all,
roughly speaking,
the same.
And so what is often done is to
take bond enthalpies,
such as this,
and average those strengths
over many different molecules
for the same bond,
so that you have an average
bond enthalpy.
And that is what you will see
plotted, or that is what you
will see a graph of.
This is a table from your book
that gives you the mean bond
enthalpy for,
for example,
CH bonds.
412 kilojoules.
It gives you the mean bond
enthalpy here for CC bonds.
348 kilojoules.
Carbon-carbon double bonds.
612 kilojoules.
And so those are the kinds of
tables that you will often see,
but remember these are average
bond enthalpies.
They are going to give you that
bond enthalpy approximately
correctly.
But not exactly correctly.
And that is going to be
important, as we are going to
see in just a moment.
Now, why in the world are bond
enthalpies important to us?
Well, they are important to us
because they determine the
enthalpy of a chemical reaction.
If the bond enthalpies in a
product of the reaction,
if those bond enthalpies are
stronger than the bond
enthalpies in the reactants.
Well, then the enthalpy of that
reaction is going to be
negative.
You are going to have an
exothermic chemical reaction.
If the bond enthalpies in the
reactants are stronger than
those in the products,
well, then we are going to have
an endothermic reaction.
So the relative bond enthalpies
are going to determine the sign
of the enthalpy of the chemical
reaction.
So let's look at this reaction
here, a very important reaction.
This is the oxidation of
glucose, very exothermic
reaction.
Minus 2816 kilojoules per mole.
This reaction is going on in
every single cell of your body.
It is this reaction that you
are using right now to maintain
your body temperature.
To move your muscles.
To repair tissue.
To think.
This oxidation of glucose is
important.
I mean, this is the reaction.
And this is the reason why we
eat, this is the reason why we
breathe, this is the reason why
we exhale, and this is the
reason why we pee.
So what do we have to do to
calculate the enthalpy for this
reaction?
Well, what we have got to do
here is take glucose,
and that is the structure of a
glucose, blood sugar,
and that of oxygen.
And we have to calculate how
much energy it is going to
require, how much enthalpy it is
going to require to break every
single one of these bonds in
glucose.
What we have to know is how
much energy is required to break
seven CH bonds.
We have to know how much energy
or enthalpy is required to break
five OH bonds.
Here are our OH bonds.
And how much enthalpy is
required to break five CO bonds.
Here are CO bonds.
And to break five carbon-carbon
bonds.
And to break one CO double
bond.
And then, finally,
we need the enthalpy to break
six molecular oxygen bonds.
So we can calculate that.
We can calculate the enthalpy
to break all of these bonds by
looking up the values from that
table that I just showed you.
The table of average bond
enthalpies.
And when we do that,
we find it is a whopping 12,452
kilojoules per mole.
That is what we are going to
need to take glucose and oxygen
to the elements,
the atomic species.
Well, then, likewise we know
that although we need to put
that much energy in to break the
bonds, we are going to get some
energy back when we make the
bonds.
So now we need to know how much
energy enthalpy we are going to
get back when we make 12 CO
double bonds and when we make 12
OH bonds.
Again, we can use our table of
average bond enthalpies to
calculate that when we make
those bonds we get 15,192
kilojoules of energy or enthalpy
back.
And then the difference between
this energy and that energy,
well, that is the enthalpy of
that reaction,
minus 2,740.
What did we do here?
Well, what we did to get the
enthalpy for the reaction is we
took the bond enthalpies for
each bond of the reactants and
we summed them all up.
And we took the bond enthalpies
for each bond of the products,
and we summed them all up.
And then we took the
difference.
That's how we got this number,
minus 2,740 kilojoules per
mole.
But now what I want you to
notice here, and this is
important, is that we calculated
these enthalpies by taking the
enthalpies of the bonds of the
reactants minus those of the
products.
When we measure enthalpies for
chemical reactions using bond
enthalpies, it is reactants
minus products.
The reason I tell you this is
because in a moment I am going
to show you another way to
calculate the enthalpy for a
reaction.
And that way will be products
minus reactants.
You've got to keep this
straight, this is reactants
minus products.
But now, you see that I just
calculated a number for that
reaction enthalpy of minus
2,740.
And the experimental value here
was minus 2,816.
Some of you are looking at your
notes like it is not in your
notes.
Is that right?
It's in the notes,
Okay.
Gee, this is what I told you
was the experiment,
this is what we calculated.
What happened here?
Well, remember that what we
used to calculate this number
was average bond enthalpies.
We didn't use the exact bond
enthalpies for every bond that
we had.
And there is a difference.
And so how can we calculate
this in a more accurate way?
I mean sometimes,
depending on what you're doing,
it is okay to have the average
bond enthalpy.
You are close enough.
It's good enough.
But sometimes it isn't.
When it isn't,
what can we do?
Is there a more accurate way?
Well, you could have the exact
bond enthalpies.
But the bottom line is that if
you had the exact enthalpies for
each bond, for each known
molecule, can you imagine the
table of numbers that you would
have to have?
In fact, such a table doesn't
even exist.
I mean just for glucose alone,
we would need 23 different
numbers, 23 different bond
enthalpies.
That is a large amount of data
that we would need to do this
exactly from the bond
enthalpies.
I am sorry?
Absolutely.
That is your job.
That is why you are here,
to sit in class and say,
gee, that's too hard,
let me think of another way to
do it.
That is what a MIT education is
all about, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
I am serious.
You're laughing.
But we do have a less
cumbersome way to handle this.
And that is using heats of
formation.
A heat of formation,
what is that?
Here it is.
I am going to define this as
delta H nought sub f.
That's a heat of formation.
It is an enthalpy.
It is the enthalpy of a
reaction that forms one mole of
a compound from the elements in
their most stable form in the
standard state,
which is one bar of pressure
here.
Let me explain that.
Here is a reaction that
produces one mole.
That is important,
one mole.
One mole of liquid water.
The enthalpy for this reaction
is minus 285 kilojoules per
mole.
That enthalpy here is defined
as the heat of formation for
water, because the enthalpy for
this reaction forms one mole of
water.
And it is forming one mole of
water from its elements,
but the elements here are in
their most stable form.
The most stable form of
hydrogen then makes up this
water here, the most stable form
at one bar pressure and at room
temperature.
And I forgot to tell you that I
was going to talk about delta
H's at 298.15 degrees Kelvin.
All of our delta H's will be
for that temperature.
Delta H does depend a little
bit on temperature.
But we are not going to do that
here.
We are going to do that in
5.60.
298.15 is the temperature at
which you are going to be
dealing with all of your delta
H's.
Anyway, H two,
that is the most stable form of
hydrogen.
And then oxygen here.
Well, that makes up one of the
elements in water.
And so, the most stable form of
oxygen at this temperature and
pressure is indeed molecular
oxygen.
And so this equation satisfies
this definition,
forming one mole of a compound
from the pure elements in their
most stable form.
Let's look at this reaction.
Here we are forming one mole of
oxygen.
And we are forming it from one
mole of oxygen.
The delta H for this reaction
is a whopping zero.
However, this is the definition
for the enthalpy of formation
for oxygen.
Because we are forming one mole
of oxygen from its elements in
their most stable form at the
standard state,
the most stable form of oxygen
is oxygen.
So the heat of formation,
the enthalpy of formation of
molecular oxygen is zero.
Such is the case for the heat
of formation of hydrogen,
H two,
or nitrogen,
N two,
or chlorine,
Cl two gas.
The heat of formation of those
compounds are all equal to zero,
because they are in their most
stable form at one bar pressure
and 298 Kelvin.
What about this reaction?
Well, this reaction here is
forming one mole of glucose from
glucose's elements in their most
stable form.
Here is the hydrogen,
molecular hydrogen,
here is the oxygen,
molecular oxygen,
and here is the element carbon
in its most stable form.
When you see this GR,
that stands for graphite.
The most stable form of carbon
is graphite at this standard
pressure and this temperature,
298 Kelvin.
The enthalpy for this reaction,
minus 1,260,
that is the heat of formation,
or the enthalpy of formation
for glucose.
Now, we looked at the
definition for the heat of
formation.
How are we going to use the
heat of formation to calculate
the enthalpy for a reaction?
That is what we are going to do
now.
Here are our reactants,
glucose and oxygen.
What we are going to do is use
the heats of formation to
calculate how much energy we
need to produce the elements of
glucose and oxygen.
The elements in their most
stable form meaning graphite,
molecular hydrogen,
molecular oxygen.
That energy,
here, is minus the heat of
formation of glucose.
Now I am taking this reaction
and going backwards.
I am going from glucose to the
elements, so this is going to be
minus the heat of formation of
glucose.
It is going to be 1,260
kilojoules.
But then, what I am going to do
is form the products.
I am going to take the elements
in their most stable form and
put them together to form the
products.
In this case,
I am going to form here six CO
two molecules.
I need the heat of formation of
CO two.
Since this is per mole,
we've got six moles of them,
it's minus 2,361.
And then I am going to take
these elements and form the
other product,
water.
And there are six moles of
So I need the heat of formation
of water times six,
minus 1,715 or something.
And then the difference between
the sum of these two energies
and these energies,
well, that is the enthalpy of
the reaction,
minus 2,816.
That is a tabular,
or energy diagram,
form.
We can also write out the
equations.
Let's do that.
Here is the reaction that
defines the heat of formation of
glucose, except I wrote it
backwards.
This is glucose going to its
elements in their most stable
form.
The enthalpy change for that
reaction is minus,
now, the heat of formation of
glucose.
Here is the reaction that
defines the heat of formation of
CO two.
The enthalpy change for that
reaction is six times the heat
of formation of CO two,
because we've got a six here.
The heat of formation is for
one mole, but now we've
multiplied this whole equation
by six so we need to multiply
that by six.
Then we've got an expression
here for the formation of six
moles of water,
so the delta H for that
reaction is six times the heat
of formation of water.
Now we are going to add them
all up.
We are going to add up the
reactions first.
And what you can see is that
there is going to be a lot of
cancellations if we did this
correctly.
This six carbon atoms in the
form of graphite is going to
cancel with this graphite on the
left-hand side.
These six moles of H two
is going to cancel with these
six moles of H two.
These three moles of O two
are going to cancel with
these three moles of O two.
And then the six O two cancels
with this six O two.
We add them all up,
and we have the reaction that
we're looking for,
the oxidation of glucose.
And then, of course,
we are going to have to add up
the delta H's for all these
reactions.
When we do so,
we get minus 2,816.
That is the enthalpy change for
this reaction.
What I just did here,
adding up these reactions and
the corresponding delta H's for
these reactions,
well, this is an example of
Hess's Law, which I think you
have seen before.
Which says that if you have two
or more chemical equations that
are added up to give another
chemical equation,
that is what we did here,
you then also have to add up
the corresponding enthalpies to
get the enthalpy change for the
overall reaction.
Now, what did we actually do?
I showed you how to calculate
the enthalpy for this reaction
both in kind of this graphical
form and also kind of this
mathematical form where we wrote
out the equations.
But the essence of what we did
is this.
What we did is we took the heat
of formation of each one of the
products, multiplied it by the
appropriate stoichiometric
number, and then summed over all
of those heats of formation.
And then we took the heats of
formation for each one of the
reactions and multiplied it by
its appropriate stoichiometric
number.
Summed over all of that and
subtracted the two to get the
enthalpy for the reactions.
For glucose,
we took one product,
CO two,
multiplied that by six for the
heat of formation,
added to the six times the heat
of formation of water,
subtracted from that the heat
of formation of glucose and that
of oxygen.
And that is our calculated
value for the reaction.
And, indeed,
that does agree with the
experimentally measured enthalpy
for the oxidation of glucose.
Why?
It agrees exactly because we
used the heats of formation.
The heats of formation are
specific for the individual
molecules that are participating
in that reaction.
It is exact.
And having tables of heats of
formation-- The tables are much
less extensive than what you
would need for the bond enthalpy
for every bond in every known
molecule.
And so these tables of heats of
formation are readily available
to you.
And you can get exactly the
enthalpy for the reaction.
But now, the second very
important point here is look at
how we calculated the enthalpy
for this reaction.
We took the heats of formation
of the products and subtracted
them from the reactants.
In the case of getting
enthalpies for chemical
reactions from the heats of
formation, it is products minus
reactants.
For bond enthalpies,
or for getting the enthalpy of
reaction from bond enthalpies,
it is reactants minus products.
You can be sure to see this
soon, like on November 2nd.
It is something you want to
remember, something you want to
know.
Questions on that?
All right.
This is important.
And I want to just make one
other brief point here about
delta H's and many thermodynamic
quantities, but delta H in
particular here.
And that is that delta H is a
state function.
That means it is independent of
path.
For example,
here I have glucose decomposed
to the elements.
Not in their most stable form,
but glucose decomposed to the
elements.
And then rearranged to form CO
two and water.
The difference between this
energy and this energy is the
enthalpy of the reaction.
And we calculated the enthalpy
of the reaction in this way,
if we had used exact bond
enthalpies.
But we also calculated the
enthalpy using heats of
formation.
Taking glucose to the elements
in the most stable form and then
recombining them.
Again, the energy difference is
minus 2,816.
What this is an example of is
the function enthalpy being a
state function.
It is independent of the path
that we took to calculate it.
You can go up here and then
come back down here.
You're going to get the same
number.
As you go up here and come back
down here.
That is what we mean by a state
function.
Again, you will talk about that
in more detail in 5.60.
Now, that takes care of
enthalpies for the moment.
What I want to talk about is
another concept,
and I want to talk about
spontaneity.
Spontaneity or spontaneous
change is certainly something
that you are familiar with.
It occurs by itself without any
outside intervention.
It has directionality.
For example,
if you put a rock near the top
of the hill and you let it go,
you know what is going to
happen.
It is going to roll down.
It is not going to roll up.
That's a spontaneous process.
If you have a gas,
say, over here,
at high pressure and then a
stop cock and a bulb here with a
vacuum, and you open the stop
cock, you know that that gas is
going to flow from high pressure
to low pressure.
It is not going to go the other
way.
That is a spontaneous process.
You know that if you put a hot
object next to a cold object,
the heat is going to flow from
the hot object to the cold
object.
It is not going to go the other
way.
However, although a change
might be spontaneous,
it may not be fast.
If you take a bottle of
ketchup, in the days when the
bottle of ketchup was a glass
bottle and you couldn't squeeze
it, and turned it upside down,
well, the ketchup has the
spontaneous tendency to come out
but it may not be fast.
What we want to understand is
what is the key to spontaneity,
in particular for chemical
reactions?
For example,
you know that iron rusts and
you don't have to do anything
about it to make it happen.
It rusts.
It turns out that iron rusting
is a very exothermic reaction,
minus 824 kilojoules per mole.
You know that if your stomach
is a little bit acidic,
that as long as you ingest
something that is basic,
that you can neutralize that
acidity.
That is also a very exothermic
reaction, minus 56 kilojoules
per mole.
Another reaction that occurs in
every cell of your body is this
transformation,
or the reaction of adenosine
triphosphate.
The hydrolyzation,
the reaction with water to
adenosine diphosphate,
this also is an exothermic
reaction.
You don't have to do anything
to make it go.
It goes.
The question is,
is delta H the key to
spontaneity?
Well, let's look at this
reaction.
This reaction is ammonium
nitrate dissolving,
essentially,
in water, to make ammonium ion
and nitrate ion.
And the question is,
is this reaction spontaneous?
This is a reaction that is
about 24-25 kilojoules per mole,
endothermic.
Does an endothermic reaction
happen spontaneously?
Well, to answer that question
we are going to have to do an
experiment.
And the experiment we are going
to do is one of these cold
packs.
And we are going to carry out
this reaction and see if it is
spontaneous.
What you are going to do is,
and the TAs can give out a few
of the cold packs,
take a cold pack and find the
little packet inside this cold
pack that has water in it.
You are going to squeeze it to
break that packet,
and then you are going to see
if this reaction goes.
If it goes, hey,
it is going to get cold because
this is an endothermic reaction.
It is going to pull heat out
from the environment.
All right.
And some of you should have
gotten hot packs.
Is an endothermic reaction
spontaneous?
Yes.
Is an exothermic reaction
spontaneous?
Yes.
Is delta H the key to
spontaneity?
No.
So it is not the key of
spontaneity.
What is the key of spontaneity?
What is the key to spontaneity?
Delta G.
That is the key to spontaneity.
The Gibbs free energy.
There it is in all its glory.
Delta G is equal to Delta H
minus T delta S.
What is delta S here?
Delta S is the change in
entropy.
What is entropy?
Entropy is a measure of the
disorder in a system.
If you have a positive delta S,
if the change in delta S,
if the sign of delta S is
positive, you are going to have
an increase in disorder,
the systems for disorder.
If you have a negative delta S
--
If the change in delta S is
negative, you are going to have
a decrease in this order.
That is going to affect delta
G.
It is not just delta H.
But the change in delta S is
going to affect the spontaneity
for a reaction.
The combination of delta S and
delta H is this delta G.
And our conditions for
spontaneity are the following.
If delta G is less than zero,
then you have a spontaneous
reaction.
If delta G is greater than
zero, then you have a
non-spontaneous reaction.
And if delta G is zero,
then you are at equilibrium.
These are the conditions for
spontaneity.
These are the conditions under
conditions of constant
temperature and pressure.
This is also important.
We won't dwell on this.
And the actual origin for these
conditions is something,
again, you are going to talk
about in exquisite detail in
5.60, but let me try to give you
a feeling here for what delta G
is.
And that is the following.
The bottom line is this.
The reason why it is delta G
and not delta H for spontaneity
is because when you have an
exothermic reaction,
for example,
that releases this delta H.
It turns out that not all of
that enthalpy,
that delta H,
not all of that delta H is
necessarily released to the
outside world to do useful work.
When you have an exothermic
reaction, it is not necessary
that all of that delta H is
released to the outside to
useful work.
Some of that delta H actually
gets stuck in the reaction,
stuck in what I call the nooks
and crannies of the product
molecules.
The amount of that energy that
gets stuck is this T times delta
S.
T times delta S has the units
of energy.
What do I mean about some of
the enthalpies getting stuck in
the nooks and crannies of the
molecules?
Well, it turns out,
and we are unfortunately not
going to have time for this
discussion, that molecules have
a way to store energy in their
vibrations.
Molecules vibrate.
These bonds move.
Molecules jiggle.
Molecules rotate.
That is a way in which
molecules can store energy.
And it is that energy that is
not available to the outside
system to do useful work.
And so the amount of energy
that is actually available to do
useful work is delta S minus
this T delta S,
the amount that gets stuck in
the products of the reaction.
And so that's why delta G here
is called the free energy,
because it is this amount of
energy that is free to do useful
work.
Delta H, that is not
necessarily all free.
Delta G is free to do useful
work.
For example,
let's look at this reaction.
This is an oxidation of
methane.
Methane is a major component of
natural gas.
When you go home for dinner and
you turn on your natural gas
stove, this is the reaction that
is going on.
You are burning methane.
A very exothermic reaction,
minus 890 kilojoules per mole.
This is the energy that you are
going to use to heat up the
water to boil the water so you
can cook your pasta.
However, not all of this energy
is going to be available to heat
up that water.
The amount that is going to be
available is delta G.
First of all,
we have to know how to
calculate delta S for this
reaction.
Well, I will show you how to do
that in a minute.
But the bottom line for this
reaction is that delta S is
minus 0.242 kilojoules per
degree Kelvin per mole.
If I put that delta S into this
expression and calculate delta
G, well, you can see I am going
to have a minus 890 plus some
number.
That is going to give me a
negative number,
and that negative number,
that delta G is going to be
less negative than delta H.
Not all of this enthalpy is
available to do useful work to
heat up that water.
Some of that energy has gotten
stuck in these internal degrees
of freedom, effectively,
of the product molecules.
On the other hand,
let's look at what your body
does.
It doesn't burn methane,
but it burns glucose,
minus 2,816 kilojoules per
mole.
If we go to calculate the
entropy for that reaction,
that entropy is positive 0.233
kilojoules per degree Kelvin per
mole.
Positive entropy means we
increase the disorder when we go
from reactants to products.
Let's calculate delta G for
this reaction.
Delta G here is this delta H
minus, then a positive number.
We are going to get for delta G
minus 2,885 kilojoules per mole.
Look at this.
Delta G for this reaction is
even more negative than delta H.
In other words,
in this case we are going to
get out --
Your body gets out of the
oxidation of glucose all of the
enthalpy to do useful work and
then some.
Your body has figured out how
to do this.
It gets even more energy out.
And it does so because it has
gotten that energy from the
nooks and crannies of the
reactant molecules,
the centrally internal motions
of the reactant molecules.
There are more ways to store
energy in the reactant molecules
than there is in the product
molecules, and so delta G here
is even more negative than delta
H.
You get all that delta H out
and then you get even more
because you don't have as many
ways to store energy in the
products as you did in the
reactants.
And so the energy has got to be
conserved.
It is going to come out.
And it comes out.
Delta G is more negative than
delta H.
This works really well.
Now here is entropy.
I told you we to know how to
calculate that,
entropy change for a chemical
reaction.
If you want to calculate that,
you need to do so in this way.
The entropy for a reaction is
the sum of the entropies for all
of the products of the reaction,
but you have to multiply it by
the appropriate stoichiometric
number, because these entropies
here are per mole,
minus the sum of the entropies
of all of the reactants
multiplied by this
stoichiometric number.
These entropies are actually
absolute values.
That not too often happens in
thermodynamics,
having an absolute value.
These are absolute values.
They are not deltas.
Those absolute values are a
result of the third law of
thermodynamics,
again, discussed in exquisite
detail in 5.60.
See you Monday.